freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher core
titel gesehen die heute gefolgt ist sehr
besonders denn ich koche heute für
martin das erste mal für einen zuschauer
durch erkläre ich ganz kurz wie das
passiert ist ich war vor dem locker und
essen mit meiner freundin und da saß am
nebentisch martini wie gesagt hat mich
dann irgendwann gequatsche meinte max
ich guck dir videos findet ihr euch gut
ich bin auch selbst hobby koch martin
kommen gleich vorbei zum frühstück gibt
es keinen cage weiß wir haben schon das
eine oder andere mal pantex hierbei
persönlicher koch aber ich kann es auch
selbst nachvollziehen man liebt halt
einfach teil takes und man sich einen
tag wirken kann was man will
jetzt hat auch keinen text gerade wenn
das ein zuschauer ist für die ich koche
ich natürlich nicht helfen dir was
anderes aus oder so sondern nicht gibt
es enthält
ich halte es aber dementsprechend kurz
um 50 gramm so die mutter schnellsten
wir dann schnappen wir uns unsere gute
bekannte schlüssel und geben die 250
gramm
dazu kommen 50 gramm zucker gehen wir
zwei teelöffel backpulver in die
mischung eine kleine prise salz und zwei
teelöffel nutzer kann dann alles
vermengen und dazu kommt jetzt ein
becher buttermilch die kite gewordene
mutter und zwei eier
da klingt schon so marti ist jetzt auch
angekommen komplett ins bild wie wärs
mal
es gibt keinen case hast du dir wünschst
frühstück sehr hast du die videos zu den
banken waren die befehle ich genau mein
ding sind und du kriegst sie heute live
und einem einzigen wahren persönlichen
koch mal im prinzip ist es irgendwann
mal gemütlich machen
ich habe nur gesehen dass wollte dich
fragen ich habe ein bisschen ein
auslandsjahr in amerika oder der
amerikanischen wurzeln ich habe keine
amerikanischen wurzeln
ich war aber während der elfte klasse
ein bisschen aussage ist ja deswegen ob
die den restlichen sechs jahre lang acht
leute das wird keine leichte aufgabe
der ein jahr in amerika gelebt hat ich
mach das mal weiter die pancakes du
kannst du gerne mal wissen was trinkt ja
aber ich freue mich wenn ich heute noch
kriegst du 16
wir gehen jetzt ein pancake in die
pfanne
[Musik]
so martin deinen teller eine riesige
portion pancakes mit glauben und
erdbeeren würde sagen mein geld klar als
er sich auch so 100 geschlossen ist ich
glaub ich hier sehr wohl ich habe mich
auch gleich er jedoch die ganze
vaterliebe sehr schöner auf muss ich
mich ganz kurzes nicht loben er abwehren
mussten sie natürlich ein bisschen
nachts müssen mit dem auch und sirup
aber sehr gespannt was zu sagen müssen
nehmen gerne die erste gabe das prinzip
ja
danach darf schon ganz in ruhe auf essen
habe ich schon mal einen ersten eindruck
mitteilen das sieht auf jeden fall auch
so hunger haben dann ganz viel geredet
hinter der kamera
martins eltern haben dass ein restaurant
das heißt der junge hat an von gutem
essen präsentiert sehr gespannt wie
lange nicht mehr wir sehen uns wieder
werde aufgegessen ist so was wie der
letzte bissen liegt noch auf einem
teller lassen wir gerne schmecken ich
habe schon alle experten ich muss
wirklich sagen zu einem gaumenschmaus
ich habe ja schon mal gemacht pancakes
dementsprechend kennt ihr ja schon aber
das müsst ihr schmecken den letzten
bissen da bin ich sehr gespannt auf
deine bewertung also die habs selbst
gehört haben desto rang hat in amerika
gelebt deshalb bin ich gespannt auf
deine bewertung was mir jetzt ein
bisschen zu wenig kredite zu geben
also ich sagen also ich bin froh dass
wir den gleichen kann weil das hat sich
auch den fall sehr gehirn also einfach
glaube ich die ganze kommen
butter drauf den dfb ja das ist ganze
fruchtige war eine sehr leichte war ganz
einfach generell muss aber ehrlich sagen
ich habe auch schon zu viel gegessen
aber das bin auf alles aber was
geschafft hast ist du hast mich zurück
an meine zeit nach amerika bublé und was
heißt das ganze in der note rede ein
teeladen es ist eine glaube ich muss
einfach nicht geben weil ich nicht auch
mit nicht alles letztmals besser
chinesen krass ist leute ja wir hatten
zehn prinzip zur frühschicht die
pancakes wirklich habt ihr gesehen sind
super easy könnt ihr er damals
funktionieren wir sehen uns zum
mittagessen und zwar geht es zum
mittagessen chicken katze das ist so was
ihn hähnchenschnitzel ultra christi ihr
wisst ihr besonders wir sind
dementsprechend will ich sagen fangen
wir an mit der hühnerbrust die haben wir
ja und dann benötige ich
frischhaltefolie und hier unsere hühner
brüste und zwar benötigen wir die
frischhaltefolie um das ticket zu
platzieren
eineinhalb zentimeter dick soll es sein
als ich fragte mich das ganze mache dann
ist vielleicht gleichmäßig ort und jetzt
wollen wir das ganze mit einer hellen
nie so passte ein ich habe übrigens alle
zutaten die ich bekommen habe ihm rede
geholt also hat mich selbst überrascht
ich musste ganz neuartigen supermarkt
und das lassen wir es einfach wären
unseren weichen vorbereitung machen
also ich mach mir ein motorrad wir
brauchen wir so ein viertel vom kohlkopf
den code schreiben wir jetzt einfach
ganz fein dann wechselten ein bisschen
durch für die textur das rezept ab
wirklich übrigens von josua weiß man das
ist einer meiner lieblings youtube
könnte ich habe schon öfters mal rezepte
von dem verwendet das einfach
komprimiert wird dazufügen darum ab
frühlingszwiebeln bein geschnitten brot
dazu kommt noch ein bisschen zeit aber
dann wenn wir das ganze noch mal durch
doch das was mir marinieren also jetzt
kommt der freestyler eigentlich habe ich
noch ein bisschen zitrone wein machen
aber ich jemals einen kleinen schluck
[Musik]
orangensaft und schillig locken denen
alles mariniert kümmern wir uns auch
schnell um die soße nicht wundern hier
ist mir die aufnahme abgeschmiert ich
habe eine soße gemacht aus dreis in
ketchup einem esslöffel aus der soße
einem esslöffel drastischer soest einem
esslöffel miso und einem teelöffel honig
ich habe keine ahnung wie lange ich gar
nicht gefilmt habe ich hoffe ich habe
das meiste mitgenommen habe auf jeden
fall hier ein kohl salat gemacht mit
chili essig salz olivenöl hier die
pannierstraße vorbereit weizenmehl
pankow unterfangen diese war alles drauf
läuft ja auch mal gerade steht der
rekord in den pfannen sind übrigens
jeweils 500 gramm pflanzenfett so dann
packen wir das check nicht in die
pannierstraße gibt hier einen sehr
leichten tritt ja sagt man macht eine
feuchte hand war jetzt auch gleich kommt
noch dass ein und sorgt und eine
trockene wenn es mit normalen weizenmehl
stolpes geben wir das 1 1 du einmal
durchs all das wirklich benetzt ist und
dann gehen wir super in die tanknadel
und dann drücken wir es auch ein
bisschen an damit groß krumen
richtig dran sticken also von der
anderen seite
und da könnte es auch schon auf
backpapier legen und mit den nächsten
weitermachen und wir legen jetzt die
ersten beiden schon mal ins öl hier für
45 minuten pro seite so parallel machen
wir schnell weiter so nummer eins ist
fertig ich hab schon mal einen teller
angerichtet ich muss noch mal von vorne
machen wir dieses kamera schon wieder
ausgegeben ist martin du endlich essen
kann ist grundlage der kursana da kommt
ein viereckiges stück karte drauf darauf
kommt die tonga zu soße die wir gemacht
haben also zwei teelöffel braucht drei
teelöffel und weil es noch nicht viel
luxus ist haben wir darüber noch mario
decke drauf und wir schneiden das ganze
in drei streifen
[Musik]
wir sehen schon bei halbzeit angekommen
bist du schon wisst schon einsam traurig
dass ich bald nur noch das abendessen
will ich komme gar nicht gar die traurig
ich freue mich dass ich den ganzen tag
über bekommt wäre geil kein grund
traurig zu sein wenn ihr wüsstet wie es
hier nicht wird euch auch das was ihr
tut mir das auto was er zu sagen lassen
uns den ersten bilder von dem er ist
geräusche alten erst auf jeden fall
stade brest nicht ob das video dann
rüber komplex ried ist das muss man sich
mal anhören das wirklich krippen erst in
ruhe auf und dann freue ich mich auf die
bewertung es ist soweit
aufgegessen ich finds geil was stört es
war sehr nichtssagend genau das was ich
mir vorgestellt hat von der küste
wenn ich das so sagen darf dass wirklich
nur zehn von zehn ohne spaß sagt kannst
dann silvester statt
das war wirklich sehr korrekten das war
schon sehr geil ich fand das chicken war
ein bisschen zu sein ich weiß nicht ob
das am ende noch ein bisschen zeit hatte
ich freue mich drauf markt das war für
mich ein kleines bisschen zu salzig und
noch einen kleinen puffer dass der staat
hat so präzise dass halt diese balance
ist im allem drum und dran würde ich
nicht gut 80
das geil also ich muss wirklich sagen
mich hat es überrascht geht es so
schnell so nice und so exotisch
irgendwie weil man würde sich einige
machen bin ich super zufrieden wir sind
18 einheit kommen wir zum abendessen und
da werde ich nochmal alles geben für
dich kommissar und essen hier mit
habe ich schon ein wasserbad mit einer
zugmaschine also dem street stark
ausgesetzt sind drei feinste stakes dazu
wird es getrüffeltem kartoffelpüree und
bohnen gemüse gehen das ist leider nicht
ganz leise also hat sich das im
hintergrund hört tut mir sehr leid
das hält er war nur konstante temperatur
von 52 grad und somit wird das fleisch
komplett perfekt durch gesagt wir müssen
uns dann nur noch auf den grill
schmeißen und es wird ein point sein das
ist weil sich die garantie für perfektes
date kartoffelchips chef genommen martin
ist übrigens auch noch neben der kamera
wir jetzt eigentlich den ganzen tag bis
auch heute mit der kamera putzen
miteinander verbracht haben gezockt und
mir über die schulter geschaut als ein
bisschen geschnitten habe und so also
das war auf jeden fall entspannter tag
bisher eigentlich wolf überrascht die
wie herzlich und menschlich ist alles
noch anders da habe ich jetzt alles ist
also für dich ist es vielleicht richtig
ein kleines team gewesen aber für mich
war das ein riesending man sagen ich
weiß nicht wie ich es besser in worte
fassen volt sehr gerne muss ich wirklich
sagen was spaß mit dir dein caddy auf
jeden fall für die lieben worte größe
die man andere der mir dieses ding
geschenkt hat wirklich einfach nur ehre
der im juli zu uns gehört dieses kochen
und er hat mir seine trüffeln brutal
geliehen und ich kann jetzt endlich
teilen so wie schneiden die kartoffeln
in etwa gleich große stücke alle
kartoffeln sind geschnitten da gehe ich
jetzt kein wasser auf und jetzt kochen
wir sie auch ich habe jetzt hier eine
packung bacon und den schneiden wir in
feine würfel schneiden noch eine rote
zwiebel in den beiden töpfen mache ich
gleich die erbsen hier drin bacon und
zwiebeln anbraten kartoffeln kochen
salmutter hier wird das denkt noch
weiter gedacht draußen heiß der grill
vor gegeben alles mal den salbei rein in
die mitte fahren ergeben wir schon mal
den bacon und wenn er so ein bisschen
angekratzt ist dann
hier die zwiebeln kommen jetzt erst mal
die boden
dazu dass leute sind jetzt fertig werden
wir also ab und dann gehen wir auch
schon direkt wieder zu bringen unseren
top 3 esslöffel butter dazu die titel
butter riecht so krank dabei wollen wir
hier mal raus und dazugeben jetzt noch
300 milliliter milch und wir haben noch
ein wenig frische muss dann und das
stampfen wehrte und dieser trip leute
sind frischer rapper drüber sind auch
gleich fertig und jetzt kommt der moment
der beiden in dem ich die stakes heraus
wurde 52 klar und hier sind sie für drei
folge garten stakes die nerven ein
bisschen komisch aus aber man mehr es
schon wenn man sie berührt wie weich und
zart schießen respekts jetzt auch fertig
den ich noch von der hitze so die geben
wir jetzt zu speck und zwiebeln mengen
wir gut durch würden so auf jeden fall
noch bis haben sieht schon sehr schön
auswendig weil dadurch die keine
netzwerk gesteckt das mal hier wo der
grill ist vorgeheizt hat 300 grad
es geht jetzt wirklich nur um diese
große die wir oben und unten zu finden
so jetzt werde ich die stakes einmal
tranchieren das fühlt sich so weich an
der not oberhaupt du hast es dir medium
rare gewünscht du kriegst das auch
hinnehmen eine großzügige portion
kartoffelpüree eine ebenfalls
prostitution von unseren speckbohnen und
dann medien real estate noch zum
kartoffelpüree der getötete sei bei
ratings soll auf das tempo
fischer verlag da ist seine abendessen
[Musik]
also martin ich habe mir die größte mühe
gegeben für dich als einer der zuschauer
wirklich ein essen rauszuhauen was sich
sehen lassen kann wir haben hier
getrüffeltem kartoffelpüree dazu bohnen
mit speck und ein medium real estate das
ist die gewünscht jetzt kannst du es
hier auch schmecken lassen also man
sagen jetzt auch eine königliche portion
natürlich blond ob als allererstes nur
das sonderproblem pietät mexiko ja dass
die schnecken leider nichts sagen ist
das jetzt in absoluter ruhe auch bei
höchstens 100 tag ist er mit dir und wir
sehen uns gleich zu bewerten
also da der letzte bissen damit geht
deine zeit als bekocht dazu ende die
bewertung steht ja hier zu feierabend
und spaß einfach wurde aufgerissen heute
umsetzen weil ich bin sprachlos über so
viel was mögen noch so nah ist der
trüffel marx hat das so viel mühe und
liebe hier schmeckt und das habe ich mit
jedem bissen einfach geschmeckt ich habe
den lehrer essen hat noch nachschlag
nicht mehr auf nachschlag zurückgenommen
kartoffelpüree mit trüffel butter sehr
fein die bohnen und der bacon mit den
zwiebeln der welt machte diese andere
textur dieses konto ihr steak war putzer
was andere sagen also das state obwohl
der rest wirklich top bar des st
am meisten zeit liebe rhein geflossen
was von der note gib mir deine skala von
1 bis 10
kann man die sprengung wurde schon
gesprengt du hast sie nämlich heute
gesprengt ist ja also es muss einfach es
sind 12 13 punkte holte das nachsehen
bisher hatte war es um 13 30 leute davon
aus dass wir uns aufgegeben ich auch
leute das macht einen glücklichen punkt
ist aber aus neue smarte nicht sagen wir
vielmals das heute zu gast war jetzt
wirklich spaß macht wenn ich sage wir
sehen uns am nächsten sonntag wieder
jetzt enorm zunehmen und bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]